when I got the call my max is going to a
presentable Asura wow that's that's big
time I'm the filming I'm the director
and when I came to deny my facility it
was like my first time seeing it again I
editor and some of my sound mixers never
explained it to me and I was like a kid
for the first time hearing about the
sound and the movements and the silver
screen and all this stuff and I just
wanted to sit and watch and stop talking
close-ups but your actors was hidden
thinking what I can reach out touch to
those faces it's so close that's truly
experiencing the magic of IMAX and the
power of a great actor got to be who you
are as well right no matter what it's
just something you can just sit there
and you're immersed in it and you just
cut up overwhelmed with the magic of
movies it's not just a visual it's what
you feel that's the immersive experience
what you feel what you see here
the frame is so overwhelming in a good
way that so much more to discover there
in the world you're almost it's almost
wrapped around you and with the sound
moving around you whatever emotion is
happening on the screen certainly going
to be something you don't feel that's
where the wonderment comes in that's
where you get to be a kid again that's
rediscovering it's taking your
experience and anointed digger and put
them on steroids you can only feel about
it wanna see an imax movie it's sitting
in the theater and then those lights go
down it's like what hollywood is
supposed to be